[Applaus]
nächster Redner für die Fraktion DIE
LINKE dr Dietmar Bartsch
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
in den Wochen nach dem furchtbaren
völkerrechtswidrigen Angriff Russlands
auf die Ukraine hat Europa hat die EU
etwas erlebt was in den letzten Jahren
jedoch sehr selten widerfahren ist es
gab Hoffnung es gab Sehnsüchte die sich
mit der EU verbunden haben ja es war ein
Einschnitt ja es war eine Zeitenwende
unbestritten aber Fakt ist auch vor dem
jetzigen erneuten Treffen des
Europäischen Rats sind diese Hoffnungen
vielfach verpufft und meine Damen und
Herren
er will immer feststellen dass die
Fraktion der Sozialdemokraten im
Europäischen Parlament aktuell in einem
Korruptionssumpf versinkt ich hätte mir
gewünscht dass das zumindest mal erwähnt
wird einer der größten Skandale den wir
in der letzten Zeit hatten meine Damen
und Herren das war unfassbar und kein
Wort dazu
und meine Damen und Herren auch die
krisenlösungsfähigkeit der Europäischen
Union die entpuppt sich immer mehr als
eine Luftnummer ja ich weiß es ist viel
getan worden und ich will auch deutlich
sagen wir als LINKE unterstützen alle
humanitäre Hilfe für die Ukraine und ja
ich sage deutlich danke an die
Hilfsbereitschaft vieler Menschen in
unserem Land die geflüchtete aufnehmen
ohne wenn und aber stimmt eben auch
254 Mal taucht das Wort Europa in ihrem
Koalitionsvertrag auf aber für die
Menschen in Deutschland gilt leider und
täglich grüßt das Murmeltier die
Tagesordnung ist wie immer aber
europäische Lösungen für die Inflation
und für die Energiekrise da ist
weitgehend Fehlanzeige meine Damen und
Herren und das hat eben
viel zu tun wenn der Bundesregierung das
Beispiel gaseinkäufe erst wollten sie
nicht nur doch dann die übergewinnsteuer
wollten sie nicht und werden andere in
Europa das lange gemacht haben haben sie
sehr lange mit einem anderen Namen und
eine Nummer kleiner das getan und was
ist eigentlich mit der europäischen
gaspreisbremse auch da keine Antwort ich
meine das us-investitionsprogramm sie
haben Fragen gestellt sie haben nach
Antworten gesucht ich hätte mir
gewünscht dass außer intensiven
Gesprächen hier klar gesagt wird was
wird denn da getan das ist mir alles
viel zu wenig ich sehe nur ein Maximum
an Selbstgerechtigkeit viele verprellte
Partner in der Union und vor allen
Dingen unzufriedene Bürgerinnen und
Bürger in Deutschland meine Damen und
Herren der Bundeskanzler sie haben in
der ihre Energiepolitik gelobt und den
schnellen Ausbau der Terminals und so
weiter aber zur Wahrheit gehört doch
auch seit Wochen herrschen Temperaturen
um den Gefrierpunkt und Millionen
Haushalte und Betriebe haben in den
letzten Wochen astronomische
Preiserhöhung für Strom und Gas im
Briefkasten vorgefunden keine dieser
Preiserhöhungen wurde vom
Wirtschaftsminister kontrolliert nur
erklärt Herr habit zwar Preiserhöhung
werden null und nichtig außer sie können
durch die Beschaffungskosten begründet
werden aber wann beginnen denn nun
endlich die Kontrollen meine Damen und
Herren in zwei Wochen ändern sich die
Tarife müssen die Leute zahlen oder
nicht das ist unklar die Menschen haben
Existenzängste und sie kommen viel zu
spät meine Damen und Herren und ich bin
noch auf einen Punkt aufmerksam machen
die Erneuerbaren haben sie hier gelobt
ja das ist ja völlig richtig sie verbal
zu loben aber ihre Energiepolitik die
ist teuer und die ist klimaschädlich und
vor allen Dingen gibt es dort eine
erhebliche Doppelmoral meine Damen und
Herren die Wind Energie der Ausbau geht
seit 2017 stetig zurück und in diesem
Jahr stagniert das auf dem Niveau des
Vorjahres der großen Koalition das ist
die Wahrheit fast die Hälfte des
produzierten Stroms in Deutschland
stammt Phasen Weise aus der Kohle meine
Damen und Herren Deutschland ist unter
der Ampel die klimadrexschleuder Europas
das ist die Wahrheit meine Damen und das
ist schlicht war die gute Nachricht ist
der die gute Nachricht ist das ein Jahr
schon vorbei ist aber ich kann nur eins
raten korrigieren Sie Ihre
Selbstzufriedenheit auch bezüglich
Europas die Bürgerinnen und Bürger haben
besseres verdient als dieses wir lassen
niemanden allein und lauwarme
ankündigungs Brüssel endlich weniger
selbst zusammen Zufriedenheit und mehr
Engagement meine Damen und Herren
herzlichen Dank
[Applaus]